ayaviri provincia de Melgar es un pueblo
indígena que se encuentra en la ruta al
cusco ellos son peruanos de condición
humilde que se dedican a la agricultura
su principal fuente de ingreso que
afirman está dañada por la sequía y por
el abandono de gobierno ayaviri se ha
declarado En paro indefinido nosotros
no centrábamos que una presidenta
podría cambiarnos una mujer pero
lamentable hemos sido traiciones de
todas las mujeres de Perú entero todavía
nos dicen que ella es una provinciana
pero lamentablemente nos están matando a
nuestros hijos inocentes nos han o se
nos han dirigido con armas mientras el
pueblo solamente teníamos un trapo y
agua para defendernos nosotros no
teníamos en la mano nada lo que más
indigna los pueblos indígenas es que el
gobierno la clase política y los medios
locales desprestigia su protesta
llamando los terroristas ellos rechazan
la acusación enérgicamente Nunca es su
terrorista nos conocemos No hay ninguna
que ningún terrorista tampoco hay
infiltrados bolivianos no hay ponches
rojos
solamente Nosotros
con nuestros palos con las ondas que
tenemos no que no nos ataquen de que ha
llegado armamento de del país boliviano
mientras mucho de sus compañeros viajan
a Lima para protestar en la denominada
marcha de los cuatro suyos en hayaviria
afirman que se mantendrán en lucha hasta
que se produzcan los cambios que ellos
esperan